do you think there's a life on mars
i like uh no longer well
already living but currently living but
also no longer living
like that we might be able to find life
as some people suspect
basic microbial life i'm not
so sure about in our own solar system
and and i do think it might be hard to
untangle if
we somehow contaminated other things as
well
so i'm not sure about this close to home
that would be really exciting yes like
do you think about the drake equation
much
of what that was what yeah what got me
into all of this yeah yeah because uh
one of the questions is how hard is it
for life to start on a habitable planet
like if you have a lot of the basic
conditions not exactly like earth but
basic
earth like conditions how hard is it for
life to start and if you find life on
mars
or find life on europa that means
it's way easier that's a good thing to
confirm that
if you have a habitable planet then
there's going to be life
and that like immediately that's that
would be super exciting because that
means
there's like trillions of planets basic
life out there
though of all the planets in our solar
system earth is clearly the most
habitable so i would not be discouraged
if we didn't find it on another planet
in our solar system true and again that
life could look very different it's
habitable for earth-like life right
but it could be totally different i
still think that trees
are quite possibly more intelligent than
humans but their intelligence
is carried out over time scale that
we're just not able to appreciate
like they might be running the entirety
of human civilization
and we're just like too dumb to realize
that they're they're the smart ones
maybe that's the alien message
it's in the trees the trees
uh yeah it's not in the uh monolith in
the utah deserts and the trees
right yeah
you